quick question what number defines you
is it your age
those lotto digits you just know will
pay off someday maybe you think there's
no number that defines you the corporate
America disagrees industry defines you
with three digits your credit score and
it influences everything from how much
you'll pay to borrow money to whether
you can buy a cell phone land a job or
rent an apartment it's not easy to make
sense of your finances I'm shaking the
sea rapport and I want to meet people
with an obsession to beat the system and
never leave money on the table
[Music]
it's become such a popular measure of
character that there's a dating service
that matches people off of it maybe it's
not for you it's definitely not for me
around 200 million Americans have FICO
scores but only about 1.5 percent of
them have that perfect 850 number one of
the folks who knows how to join the 850
Club is Stan Kelman he learned to game a
system after his score fell below 600
during the Great Recession
let's give him a ring and find out how
he did it
hey Stan thanks so much for taking the
time to chat thank you for having me
what moved you to want to achieve an 850
credit score I just happen to have the
misfortune of graduating with my MBA
into the recession and got into some
debt
in the process of settling that debt if
my credit score dropped what it's like
to live in a low score and really sucks
if you have a mark on your credit report
it will not go away for seven years of
ten if you have a bankruptcy you
mentioned that you had negotiated with
your creditors how did you go about
doing that
you'll get daily collection calls and
they'll want you to make a payment what
you don't realize is once you make a
payment your clock gets reset by law
after hundred eighty days of non-payment
is when there's required to write it off
while counting purposes and right before
the 180 day mark is when you can call
them and make a deal I could settle some
cards for his lowest twenty cents on a
dollar you're not paying back what he
promised to pay back but at the same
time they're big banks I've got billions
of dollars from the government and
bailout funds and they didn't so that
was my own personal bailout why didn't
you just stop when you got to 780 why
did you try to get that elusive 850
because that's my personality
I wanted my perfect score the scores are
not developed for you they're developed
for the banks to evaluate your credit
worthiness they are not a measure of
your personal financial health it can be
deep in debt and have a perfect score
and that's not good for you and it's
better to have a middling score but have
no debt so let's look at how these
credit scores are weighted people with
perfect 850 scores never make late
payments the 850 years used may be 5% of
a big credit limit and have had a
diverse mix of loans and card accounts
over the years they also haven't applied
for any new credit recently it's not the
fairest system but you really don't need
to be perfect to get it to work for you
why is Brent Kong founder Janet Alvarez
racer score 300 points and she's got
tips on how to raise your score and keep
it there
in order to get the perfect 850 or 860
credit score it's gonna take sort of
impeccable performance on every aspect
of your credit but you don't really need
it you don't need a perfect score to get
the best rates or the best offers you
just need a really good school younger
people are inadvertently penalized
because you're younger you're just not
going to have a long credit history and
to get the maximum boost out of this
component of your credit score you're
gonna want to credit history in 30 years
or longer even if your credit isn't
great if you do qualify for a more
credit ask for higher credit limits on
your existing cards or try to get new
cards again that improves your credit
utilization ratio so that a boost your
score it can boost it by something like
50 to 100 points within a month and
depending on how much additional credit
you take on there's a different score
generated for the type of loan or the
type of credit you're seeking so for the
purposes of credit cards or a car loan
or home loan you might get different
scores and that's just because they're
looking at different selection criteria
based on what you're borrowing for so
get to work on your score give yourself
some credit along the way
[Music]
you
you